but it's interesting to think about
uh the evolution of programming
as we come up with these whole new set
of algorithms in machine learning in
artificial intelligence and what's going
to win out because there could be a new
programming language yeah it could be
um I mean we I just mentioned Julia I
think there's a lot of ideas behind
Julia that
Mojo shares
um what what are your thoughts about
Julia in general
um
um so I would I will have to say that
when we launched Mojo the
one of the biggest things I didn't
predict was the response from the Julia
community and so
um I was not I mean I've okay let me
take a step back I've known the Julia
folks for a really long time they were
they're an adopter of llvm a long time
ago they've been pushing state of the
art in a bunch of different ways Julie
is a really cool system
um I had always thought of Julia as
being mostly a scientific Computing
focused environment right and and I
thought that was its focus I neglected
to understand that one of their missions
is to like help make python work end to
end and so I think that was my my error
for not understanding that and so I
could have been maybe more sensitive to
that but um but there's major
differences between what Mojo's doing
what Julia's doing so as you say Julia
is not python
right and so one of the things that a
lot of the Julia people came out and
said is like okay well if we put a ton
of more energy and ton more money or
engineering or whatever into Julia maybe
uh that would be better than starting
Mojo right well
I mean maybe that's true but it still
wouldn't make Julie into python
so if you've worked backwards from the
goal of let's build something for python
programmers without requiring them to
relearn syntax
then Julia just isn't
there right I mean that's a different
thing right and so if you anchor on I
love Julia and I want Julia to go
further then you can you can look at it
from a different lens But the lens we
were coming at it was hey everybody is
using python python isn't syntax isn't
broken let's take what's great about
Python and make it even better and so
it's just a different starting point so
I think Julie is a great language the
community is a lovely Community they're
doing really cool stuff but it's just a
different a slightly different angle
but it does seem that python is quite
sticky uh is there some
uh philosophical almost thing you could
say about why python by many measures
seems to be the most popular programming
language in the world well I can tell
you things I love about it maybe that's
one way to answer the question right so
huge package ecosystem
super lightweight and easy to integrate
it has very low startup time
right so it was startup time you mean
curve or what yeah so if you if you look
at certain other languages you say like
go and it just takes a like Java for
example it takes a long time to compile
all the things and and then the the VM
starts up and the garbage clusters kicks
in and then it revs its engines and then
it can plow through a lot of Internet
stuff or whatever right
um python is like scripting like it's it
just goes right python has very low
compile time like so you're not sitting
there waiting python integrates into
notebooks in a very elegant way that
makes exploration super interactive and
it's awesome right python is also um
it's like almost the glue of computing
because it has such a simple object
representation a lot of things plug into
it that Dynamic meta programming thing
we were talking about also enables
really expressive and beautiful apis
right so there's lots of reasons that
you can look at
technical things that python has done
and say like okay well this is actually
a pretty amazing thing and any one of
those you can neglect people will all
just talk about indentation
and ignore like the fundamental things
but then you also look at the community
side right so python owns machine
learning
machine learning is pretty big yeah and
it's growing and it's growing right and
it's growing in importance right and so
and there's a reputation of prestige to
machine learning to where like if you're
a new programmer and you're thinking
about like which programming language do
I use well I should probably care about
machine learning therefore let me try
Python and what kind of builds and
builds a bit and even go go back before
that like my kids Learn Python
but not because I'm telling them to
Learn Python but because were they
rebelling against you or what no no well
they also learn scratch right and things
like this too but it's because python is
taught everywhere right because it's
easy to learn right and because it's
pervasive right and there's my day we
learn Java and C plus plus yeah but
uphill both directions but yes I guess
python is the main language of teaching
software engineering schools now yeah
well and if you look at if you look at
this there's these growth Cycles right
if you look at what causes things to
become popular and then gain in
popularity there's reinforcing feedback
loops and things like this and I think
python has done again the whole
Community has done a really good job of
building those growth loops and help
Propel the ecosystem and I think that
again you look at well you can get done
with just a few lines of code it's
amazing